the trolley dilemma states if we
consider that everyone has equal rights
then we would be doing something wrong
in sacrificing one even if our intention
was to save five
therefore isn't it objectively immoral
to force vaccination even if the outcome
was net positive on saved lives
um
i'm going to say i don't think this is a
simple question but i do think you can
tell that we are not even attempting to
grapple with yeah i think that's right
let's put it this way you will discover
if you delve into the public health
discussion about um vaccines and other
treatments
that we are just simply refusing to use
the tools at our disposal that we know
work things like all-cause mortality
right
um things like uh absolute risk
reduction right we have the tools
they're named they're well understood
and we're not using them because
somebody is playing a game in which they
want to convince us of things that
aren't true but but the tools uh exist
in the case of
is it all right to compel vaccination uh
in order to save lives
this is a difficult one there is a
strong argument to be made
that it's never okay and what we have
said here is that actually in light of
the corruption of our systems they have
one and only one tool that they are
actually morally entitled to and that is
persuasion if they can persuade us to
take it fine if they can't persuade us
they don't get to mandate it because
they're frankly uh dangerously corrupt
and that is visible on many different
fronts
were they not corrupt
is there a scenario we could paint in
which
vaccination
was
morally
mandatable
i believe we could paint those scenarios
i believe they would be exceedingly rare
but we are not using the tools that we
would need in this case to justify any
such thing right
the fact is and basically i would say
anybody who is simply counting lives
is either
willfully ignorant of the calculus or a
liar all right because the fact is
you cannot trade a life of a child
against the life of an elderly person
it is immoral to do so right the amount
of goodness lost if you lose a child
is large because they have so much life
ahead of them and so much room for bad
things to happen and somebody who's
already at the end of their life even if
they're lost it's not
it's not a simple calculation of a life
and the fact is these tools exist
we know this insurance companies know
the difference between an old person and
a young person why is it that that is
not why is it that this was famously
done after 9 11. right yeah of course
and the point is yeah nobody really
likes talking about the fact that lives
aren't of equal value but this is a
simple thing but the point is how much
life was left ahead of you right that is
absolutely essential and it is built in
to the nature of being a human being
right our purpose as adult human beings
is to make the world decent and
hospitable for generations to come
and we are falling down
on that responsibility
and we are harming children and it's
completely unacceptable and to do so
with the analytical tools necessary to
make these calculations simply not being
deployed and us pretending as if they
don't exist is preposterous
is dating a vaccinated person dangerous
in regards to the spike protein shedding
by the way i love your show hope you
never stop
well look i've heard they're shedding
stuff yeah um no i've seen i've seen no
evidence either way i find it almost
impossible to imagine that a person
could shed enough spiked protein in a
way that other people would contact it
that it's worth thinking about that said
that's my gut too on this let's put it
this way i wasn't i didn't see how
people with a good diet were going to be
vitamin d deficient i now see it so is
there something here failure as as as
dawkins has famously said right failure
to imagine is not an argument right so
my gut on this is like i don't think so
but i've seen no evidence either way yep
my wife and i had covered last month and
i had it once in april 2020.
the home country of my wife requires vax
for entry so it's facts who don't see
your family
where to get information on vax after
covid
and its risks
i've seen
nothing
i've seen the recommendation that you
get super immunity if you have both
which is
ridiculous in which case you know if
that were true it's the only disease
known in which that's the case i think
they pre-bunked that one they pre-punked
it um
but
i haven't seen any research and you know
the there's so much research now i don't
claim to be up to date but i haven't i
have specifically not seen anything on
um
on the effects of vaccination after
having covid
with the
caveat that there might be a
what is it an antibody dependent
enhancement problem
um
maybe
but that's just that's like that's um
the speculation it's not data
one thing is
we and others have successfully
embarrassed these people on the subject
of natural immunity
and
it is now acknowledged that natural
immunity is superior to vaccine immunity
anywhere that reasonable people gather
does that mean that these systems will
be updated
so that your natural immunity can
substitute i don't know because
obviously there's something about this
it's a campaign to vaccinate everybody
irrespective of whether it makes any
freaking sense to vaccinate them right
so that driving force is not necessarily
blunted by the update on natural
immunity but the update on natural
immunity has occurred and people are now
backtracking where they made insane
claims is it true
that um
vaccine immunity plus natural immunity
is super immunity
it is almost certainly a very tiny tiny
tiny bit true but in no way that should
matter to anyone right now it is also
possible
that to the extent that natural immunity
is protective that giving you a vaccine
that then detains a bunch of the immune
system mesmerizing it with antigens that
has been warned about by your infection
could depress your immunity and this is
the next thing we should be
investigating yeah is that to the extent
that they're saying well of course you
should get the vaccine because everybody
should get a vaccine and really you want
more vaccine rather than less vaccine
and that whole thing right
the point is look
even if it is technically true that
there is a tiny bit of extra immunity
that you will get if you have had an
infection and then you get a vaccination
is there a period in which the
vaccination compromises your natural
immunity by
by
gumming up the the immune cells that
were alerted to the infection itself
probably and i mean
god damn it but like vaccination is
supposed to be a way to get exposed to
the thing without having to take the
risk of being exposed to the thing
like this is
a side version that's supposed to be
safer than and equal to
and yeah these vaccines aren't exactly
vaccines and so that may be part of the
argument that's hiding but they can't
really say that can they but if it's an
actual vaccine
then having the
immunity garnered from actually being
exposed to the thing and having your
body man its defense
is simply better
than having the sidelined version that
is safer yeah the sideline version which
is if we're talking about like an
attenuated virus vaccine like right a
traditional
vaccine that would be safer
but a way to a way to get your immune
response to be mounted in the same way
but without the risk in this case
the
vaccine in question
is so narrowly targeted that it couldn't
possibly be the equal of natural
immunity right it just can't be not even
in principle right so
um and also you know
they're like a thousand things in which
we're trying to raise the attention that
the public health authority is actually
just shuffling papers and pretending to
be interested in your health right why
is it not interested in t cells
this is where the better immunity comes
from right it's obsessed with b cells
why because you know what they are
you've heard of them right and so the
point is to mesmerize you
they're going to talk about
antibody response right oh greater
antibody response you know and the point
is it's an accounting game it's very
hard to detect how much t cell immunity
you have but that's the durable immunity
that is likely to be more protective and
an actual infection will give it to you
and their vaccines will not
and so
i guess i you know as always the
question is something like how many
times would these people have to be
wrong before we're entitled to stop
listening to them
[Music]